si sabemos que el área de un círculo es
igual a 36 y el área es igual a 36 y
podremos a partir de esta información
calcular el perímetro te recomiendo
detener el vídeo para que lo pienses por
tu cuenta si en efecto a partir del área
podemos determinar el perímetro con el
área podemos encontrar el radio usando
la fórmula para área y teniendo el radio
podemos encontrar el perímetro vamos a
hacer eso el área es igual a 36 pi pero
también es igual a pi por radio al
cuadrado y por radio al cuadrado
reescribiendo esto tenemos que pi pi por
ra por radio al cuadrado es igual a 36
pi y aquí podemos dividir entre pide a
ambos lados entre pi y aquí también
entre pi para obtener lo siguiente estos
pisos se cancelan y entonces obtenemos
que r al cuadrado es igual a 36 aquí
tenemos que sacar raíz cuadrada
usualmente si esto fuera únicamente un
problema de álgebra r tendría dos
valores
6 6 pero aquí r no puede ser menos 6
porque r es una distancia r es algo
positivo sale entonces r el radio es
igual a 6 esto es 6 y teniendo que el
radio de 6 podemos utilizar la fórmula
de perímetro sabemos que el perímetro es
igual a 2 por pi por radio o bien es
igual a pi por diámetro pero aquí la
fórmula que sirve es la primera porque
ya tenemos el radio y entonces el
perímetro es igual a 2 por pi por 6 que
es el radio y eso es igual a 12 y 12
entonces fue muy sencillo verdad a
partir del área podemos determinar el
radio y conociendo el radio podemos
encontrar el perímetro